how's it going everybody we recently had
some time to tool around Holland Valley
and far cry 5 and want to show you where
the game is out in terms of clearing out
posts fans of Far Cry 5 will find out
post clearing to be very familiar with
the usual mix of stealth alarms animals
in cages and Randall wildlife attacks if
you're not so stealthy you'll also see
the typical enemy reinforcement system
haulin valley where the game takes place
is broken up into regions controlled by
cult leaders similar to the narcos in
Ghost Recon wildlands as you liberate
outpost and flam based roadside racists
you will accumulate resistance points
that fill a meter and when that meter
gets to a certain point the region won't
push back that probably means more heavy
and aggressive units will start to show
up in our demo the regions were
controlled by jakub faith and John and
we were told that taking them out would
get the attention of the main cult
leader we're not really sure if he'll be
powerful enough to go straight at each
region's leader at the start or need to
do low-level missions in several regions
to build up enough power that being said
the entire game can be played co-op so
maybe bringing a friend along is the
thing to do
alright let's get to some gameplay of a
mission where we cleared a fertilizer
outpost and then went hunting for a
coked-out supermoose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have forgotten where we came from we
have forgotten they are no longer we
will become killers we will become ten
righteous life we will become strong
[Music]
[Music]
for a Polish [ __ ] but that fertilizer
was being used to build all sorts of
explosives maybe we can use it to our
advantage
deputy will use your help
we got a [ __ ] nightmare moose in our
hands Eden skate did something to it
with drugs now the damn thing's insane
it's tracked it down to the outskirts of
the valley
we sent a squad to take it down but we
haven't heard from them since it needs
to be put down before its next rampage
but you need to be ready damn thing's a
monster
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]